[Musique]
vous n'avez pas peur les coups de soleil
un petit peu des fois fait chaud il fait
très chaud c'est pas difficile de
travailler toute cette chaleur
si un peu et pour la peinture ça gêne
pas non pas du tout elle coûte soleil ça
va à coup sûr les tailleurs jusqu'à lui
dit quoi et l'après midi enfin on me
lâche rice autorisé combien d'heures par
jour
on travaille des jardins jours c'est dur
ah oui c'était sous cette chaleur la
tranche à l'eau vous commencez à quelle
heure le matin comme à 18h45 ou et pas
commencé plus tôt ce serait pas mieux
ça c'est moi quatre ans alors il fait
chaud oui oui c'est dur pour travailler
vous avez soif n'ont pour le moment pas
soif et vous buvez combien de litres par
jour quand vous travaillez vous
travaillez comme ça c'est que 6 litres
par jour il passé alors monsieur que
pensez vous de cette chaleur
frechaut nous sommes obligés de boire
très souvent et
on arrive
avoir l'estomac gorgée de bière voir ce
que nous faisions beaucoup de bière et
c'est assez désagréable parce qu'obligés
là
obligé d'arrêter de temps à autre
tellement
le corps est imprimée de dessel de la
soeur alors
dit sous cette chaleur vous avez
l'impression d'être plus fatigué à la
fin de la journée
oui beaucoup pourquoi ben y'a déjà le
soleil qui nous accable sur la tête à
orpond ses pertes tout en train de boire
tout seul oui ça vous coûte cher de
boire comme ça aubin ont beaucoup passé
c'est le patron qui payent alors vous
avez une prime ouais bon alors ça va oui
mais le soleil est dur sur toujours en
lui
[Musique]